closing the loop on a couple of other
stories this is from like way uh it's
from the weekend at cpac in texas
a marjorie taylor green and actually
this may not have been at cpac i think
maybe it is maybe it isn't it was around
the time that cpac took place marjorie
taylor green is insisting
there were no trump rioters on january
6th
it was antifa
but she also says
that the trump people are being treated
poorly by being held in pre-trial
detention well but so what real honest
i'm always honest about it i was upset
that day i was a brand new member of
congress i'd worked very hard on
objecting to joe biden's electoral
college votes because i believe that
that was my role and what i was what i
wanted to do and yeah that was her
desire i believe it's the right thing i
would do it today i'd do it tomorrow
but i was very upset i never expected
anything like that and when it happened
i thought this is the antifa and no one
can convince me it was
so-called trump supporters
but and and we know there's a lot wrong
there and i cannot wait for invest real
investigation is that what's going to
happen yeah we will be real but let me
say this though
and then marjorie taylor greene also
pointing out they will indeed do
investigations
of
the investigation into january 6th if
they get into power in november
that i believe her i do believe that
she's actually telling the truth about
that
the weirdest thing about this
is that
marjorie taylor green
on the one hand wants us to believe
the people being investigated
and charged for the things they did on
january 6 2021
are being treated poorly
because they're trump supporters
but at the same time she insists
they weren't really trump supporters it
was antifa for which of course there is
no evidence whatsoever
so how could both be true how could it
be
that the trump supporters didn't do
anything on january 6th and also the
trump supporters from january 6th aren't
being treated correctly by the justice
system and by the jail system in which
they are being held in pre-trial
detention well i'm sure she can find
some way to explain it to people who pay
no attention to reality it would
probably be something like well here's
what happened the vile is i'm pretend
i'm a [ __ ] right pretend i'm trying to
figure out a way to make both of these
things plausible here's the way that
they would do it
there were trumpists in dc on january
6th
but none of them committed any acts of
violence or property crime or anything
they weren't the writers
antifa did the riots and then law
enforcement arrested
innocent trump supporters who were there
just for the rally and is treating them
poorly
in bad conditions
one guy without vegan food in pretrial
detention i think that's the way someone
like marjorie taylor green
puts the two stories together it wasn't
antifa
it was trump supporters
the science has shown us that one of the
ways to achieve consistent deep sleep is
to lower your core body temperature at
night it also is just really
uncomfortable to be too hot when you're
trying to sleep our longtime sponsor
chilisleep makes customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions that improve
your sleep by keeping you cool at night
chili sleeps cube and ooler sleep
systems are hydro powered mattress
toppers they fit on your existing
mattress and they provide the ideal
sleep temperature
you can keep your bed as cool as 55
degrees or as hot as 115. i like 62
personally
stop waking up hot and sweaty in the
middle of the night with chilly sleep
you'll stay cool all night and stay
asleep you're really going to experience
a totally different bed when you install
this thing chilly sleep has been a total
game changer for me i didn't even know
it was possible to cool your bed down
like this before discovering chili sleep
it's fantastic and chili sleep is the
only company on the market doing it like
this you'll get thirty percent off your
new cube or uhler sleep system at
chilisleep.com
pacman the link is down below